هذا المؤتمر ياتي بعد محادثات مطوله بين
بلينكن والمسؤولين
الاسرائيليين بالفعل ويبدو ان هنالك في
حديث بلينكن كثير من التماهي ايضا مع
المواقف الاسرائيليه المطروحه في مساله
الحرب على قطاع غزه وفي مساله الصفقه التي
يجري الحديث عنها ب شان تبادل الاسرى
بلينكن كان واضحا في تطرقه الى هذه
المساله مساله رد حماس على مقترح الصفقه
وما جاء في قمه باريس واشار في هذا السياق
بان رد حماس كما قال يوجد فيه امور لا
يمكن قبولها دون ان يحدد ما هي هذه الامور
حقيقه لكنه قال بانها تبقي المجال مفتوحا
من اجل التوصل الى صفقه هذا هو ربما
العنوان الابرز في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي ل
بلينكن وهو ياتي ايضا
متماهياً الموقف الاسرائيلي الذي عبر عنه
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو في المؤتمر
الصحفي هذا المساء لان بنيامين نتنياهو لم
يقل بانه يرفض الرد حماس جمله وتفصيلا هو
لم يستخدم هذه العباره بنيامين تنياه كان
ربما اكثر دبلوماسيه في في رده وقال بان
اسرائيل لن تخضع للشروط التي وضعتها حماس
من اجل التوصل الى صفقه لتبادل الاسرى ايه
واضح بان بنيامين نتنياهو يميل في هذا
السياق الى رفض المقترح مقترح حماس فيما
يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار ووقف الحرب
والانسحاب الاسرائيلي من قطاع غزه لكن
بنيامين نتنياهو لا يغلق الباب لا يوصد
الباب يبقيه مواربا كما يبدو على مزيد من
الحوار وعلى مزيد من المناقشات وهذا ايضا
ما اكد عليه وزير الخارجيه انتوني بلينكن
في حديثه هذه الليله وهذه نقطه في غايه
الاهميه بمعنى ان رد حماس الان يدرس رد
حماس ما زال مفتوحا للحوار والنقاش والباب
لم يوصد بعد على اتمام صفقه ربما
المقترحات التي وضعتها حماس قد تكون قابله
للتفاوض او قد تكون قابله للنقاش والحوار
في مقبل الايام بطبيعه الحال مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي سوف يجتمع غدا لمناقشه هذه
المقترحات لكن زين ربما ايضا مجلس الحرب
لن يصدر قرارا واضحا غدا بامكاننا ربما
القول ان كان س تقبل اسرائيل اي هذا
الموقف الذي طرحته حماس او ترفضه وبالتالي
ابقاء الامور مفتوحه الى مزيد من النقاشات
والحوارات في مقبل الايام لكن واضح بان
الان هنالك انسجام في المواقف الامريكيه
والاسرائيليه في رفض بعض المقترحات
الموجوده في رد حماس وربما هي تلك الامور
التي كان عبر عنها بنيامين نتنياهو في
الايام الماضيه المتعلقه بوقف الحرب ووقف
القتال والانسحاب من من قطاع غزه على وجه
التحديد